we have to leave you with some good  vibes courtesy of vin diesel and his  newest co-star i love this so much rita  moreno yeah so vin shared the news via  instagram that rita is joining the  highly anticipated fast x to play his  grandmother and they are clearly each  other's biggest fans already take a look  and we will see you next time family  it's been my dream forever  to work with  rita moreno and the fact that she's here  playing my grandmother  makes my soul smile i'm so blessed you  know what i think i was getting i think  my old age was waiting for you to invite  me  isn't that nice  and i'm here and the answer is yes i'll  do it  and yes not only do it i'm tickled  i'm tickled the health and tickle i'm so  thrilled it's gonna be such fun  thank you so much oh thank you i love  you thank you